Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Video heute ein absoluter Traum
wir sind bei Eric zu Hause und heute
wird ein Tag lang nur gegrillt wir haben
schon was feines vorbereitet es gibt zum
Frühstücks Eier mexikanische Eier nach
pharmaart das geht ganz einfach wir
haben ja meistverkehrs die werden wir
gleich schön knusprig auf dem Grill
machen heute alles am Grill dazu gibt es
Spiegeleier sind schon so bisschen Väter
bisschen chedder Gemüsezwiebel die ist
das es wird sehr sehr lecker bisschen
von Rapsöl drauf haben wir die schön
knusprig werden und so backen wir die
jetzt einfach schön knusprig aus
oh ja man hört schon wie sich die
Konsistenz so langsam verändert so
während das da drüben knusprig wird
haben wir uns immer unsere Tomaten nein
den Stamm raus schnell mal so ein paar
Chance aus den Tomaten das machen wir
gleich auch drüben auf unserer planscher
so Knoblauchzehe mach hier mal ein
bisschen Platz die Blasen die die werfen
auch dadurch dass du wie man es auch tun
sollte so eine Patina ja ja was ich so
in dieser in diesen Tortilla gerade tut
so muss das Ganze trinken ganz wichtig
ist die Regel die immer geht wenn man
sowas angepostet ist und so holt da muss
man so mit möglichst viel Platz
voneinander platzieren damit nicht
irgendwie so Kondenswasser dann
aufgesogen wird weil wir wollen dass sie
schön knusprig bleiben etwas Öl wieder
drauf wenn wir unsere Junkie Boy Zwiebel
hier guck mal bitte guck mal die sind
extra so groß so ein Bauern am Lech noch
dazu
und mit unserem Knoblauch
so dann haben wir natürlich noch einen
weiteren Stargast hier schon wirklich
auch so geil so eine scharfe ist dass du
mit ja ja liebe ich ja ne ich liebe
Wirklich sowieso scharfes Essen aber ich
habe echt Bock dieses Jahr ein bisschen
Grill konnte noch zu fetzen das ist
wirklich so ein Thema was wir noch so
gar nicht gemacht haben eigentlich so
ja ja das mechanisch steigt dann so ein
Paprika Geruch auch wenn die Nase
[Musik]
so Tomaten drauf das wirklich andere
Level so an sich macht man die weatheros
mit so einer richtigen Tomatensoße aber
ich habe sogar Lust drauf das ist ein
bisschen stückig bleibt also dann
schnapp mir jetzt unsere schöne Farbe
wirklich nur noch keine
[Musik]
boah das sieht absolut krank aus Digger
als nächstes machen wir unsere
Spiegeleier ein bisschen Öl wieder
dann sieht man so dass
ich lege schon mal die Tortillas bereit
bis gleich hin
Avocado schneide ich schon mal auch so
in grobe Würfel im wilde Sachen geplant
für heute ich sage wirklich heute lohnt
sich auch wirklich dran zu bleiben weil
wir haben so eine nice Abwechslung Zeit
zum Anrichten wir nehmen uns die
wunderschönen Spiegeleier legen die ganz
simpel und drauf ihr seht schon auch die
Spiegeleier sind knusprig fällt dir das
die Arbeiten noch richtig jetzt nehmen
wir von unserer Salsa ein wenig feines
so um die Eier herum ein wenig Cheddar
Käse nehmen wir ein paar Würfe aus
unserer Avocado etwas Fetakäse und ich
fehlen dafür dass Koriander die
angedreht Chorizo das Limette drüber und
das hier ist Tahin der Geheimtipp und
hier haben wir das Frühstück vom Grill
man würde es nicht denken
[Musik]
Mamma Mia ey wirklich ich finde es so
geil ich bin so schön guck dir das an
und jetzt achtung Achtung
[Gelächter]
es riecht so schön nach Mais von den
Tortillas es riecht ultra würzig von dem
ganzen gegrillten
[Musik]
crazy das ist wirklich unfair das
Frühstück man muss es auch schnell essen
damit die Tortillas ihren Crunch waren
weil der ist so geil so vielseitig ich
habe beim Kochen auch beim Grillen
kannst du so geile Sachen machen
wir sehen uns beim Mittagessen Freunde
was für ein Frühstück es wird Zeit für
leckeres Mittagessen und das hier haben
wir eingekauft Dry Aged Rinderfilets
dann grünen Spargel Rosmarin Kartoffeln
und hier das einzige was in
Anführungszeichen vorbereitet habe bzw
was ich noch im Kühlschrank hatte man
braucht es nicht eine leckere je eine
kalbsream so Leute packen wir uns mal
ein paar von unseren Kartoffeln ich habe
extra kleine festkochende Kartoffeln
genommen und die werden wir jetzt
vierteln und das Wichtige ist sie müssen
klein sein weil wir sie nicht vorkochen
logischerweise also ich hätte jetzt auf
dem Grill den Topf mit Wasser aufsetzen
können wollte mal die Kirche im Dorf
lassen machen das mal genauso dort ein
bisschen länger natürlich wenn man die
nicht vorgekocht darauf gibt aber
einfach so schöne kartoffelviertel
Zombie mache ich das
wenn die geschnitten sehen geben wir sie
wieder in ihre Schale dann stehen wir
auch mal auf nein ich gehe jetzt ins
sitzen manchmal noch einen Move davor
und wichtigen wichtig
du bist so faul dicker so ein richtiger
so entspannter grilltag da darf man auch
mal faul sein und auch damit
[Musik]
wird ja gearbeitet wo gehobelt werden
fallen auch Späne ne das kommt Tobi den
Spruch den habe ich auch alles frei was
ist Halle 2 alle 2 ja achso das mein
Podcast dein Podcast habe ich gemeinsam
mit Dave ja da veröffentlichen wir jeden
Mittwoch eine neue Folge wo wir ganz
viele Sachen verraten die wir sonst noch
nicht in den Videos erzählen aber warum
erzähle ich dir das also check mal den
Link wenn ihr euch für unseren Podcast
interessiert hört mal eins auf Youtube
Spotify sonst überall
lohnt sich mal reinzuschauen weil da
könnt ihr mich mal richtig kennenlernen
so Deckel drauf während der anderen
Vorbereitung
wir geben jetzt unsere
dass sie so widerspenstig ist macht mich
sehr stolz weil das Zeichnen eine gute
Schür aus
heute komplett egal
als nächstes
so ein anderes Video heute einfach aber
ich hoffe ihr könnt so ein bisschen so
die Vibes fühlen entspannten Sommertag
nichts außer geiles Essen sich vorne
besteigen
[Musik]
zur Zeit unsere
Spargel
man sieht jetzt auch der ist quasi ein
bisschen durchgegart so alles fertig der
Grill gibt jetzt noch mal richtig Gas
wir sind bei 100 Grad wir warten bis wir
gleich bei 300 sind und dann legen wir
das Rinderfilet ab 300 Grad es wird
ernst ein bisschen Olivenöl Rinderfilet
ist ja also viele generell ist ja
relativ so leicht im Geschmack und so
dry age holt ja noch viel Geschmack raus
deshalb denke ich dass eine mega
Kombination jetzt ordentlich Salz dran
auch das ganze Brett mache ich voll
nojoke damit ich gleich die Ränder schön
drüber ziehen kann es ist Zeit ich
erhebe mich wieder
von diesem gemütlichen Stuhl aufzustehen
aber hoch mit dem Deckel wir machen das
Ganze jetzt nicht auf der planscher die
ist nämlich aus Edelstein sondern mit
dem gusseisernen Rost geben jetzt
einfach unser wunderbares Filetsteak
auf das Rost dass wir das ganze so ein
bisschen über eine Minute liegen dann
drehen wir es um 45 Grad um so ein
schönes Schachbrettmuster rein zu
bekommen
dann wollen wir mal
[Musik]
das gleiche ist noch von der anderen
Seite dann ziehen wir es in der
indirekten Zone noch gar und dann sehen
wir uns mal anrichten es ist soweit wir
richten das Ganze an schöne Stangen von
unserem grünen Spargel in die Mitte dann
nehmen wir hier unser
Filet Kartoffel
no joke so viel Farbe kriegt man glaube
ich auf andere Art und Weise überhaupt
nicht der ansatzweise an so Kartoffeln
dran
obwohl wir sie nicht vorgekocht haben
sind sie richtig schön cremig innen drin
schneidet sich sehr sehr schön schöne
Farbe super weich innen drin das ist ein
bisschen von der Jürgen
[Musik]
ich sage euch wirklich Leute kein so wie
kein nichts perfekte Garstufe die Soße
ist wie ein Lack
dann braucht man auch wirklich nicht
viel davon
oder grüner Spargel
noch richtig schön bist also dazu kann
man nicht ganz viel sagen guckt euch
einfach an
es ist wunderschön genau wie schön ist
es gerade es ruft nach uns es ruft nach
Abendessen wir müssen locker machen was
machen wir ganz einfach ohne aufzustehen
öffnen wir den Grill und geben die
Maiskolben drauf
dann unser Feta wir machen ja ein
bisschen klein
und hinter
her so sieht das ganze dann aus wir
rollen gleich nämlich unsere Maiskolben
durch diesen Käse durch halbieren eine
Limette
brauchen wir gleich am Ende und den
Koriander packen wir auch ein bisschen
durch und das sind unsere Vorbereitungen
fürs Abendessen
[Musik]
das ist das Minimum ich habe jetzt
richtig Lust drauf das obwohl ich hier
schon raus könnt ruhig noch mehr Farbe
dran machen davon muss man keine Sorge
haben so so stelle ich mir so mein mein
Lebensabend auch für die ganze Zeit so
sitzen Kochen grillt einfach so einfach
abchecken und jetzt
wir drehen das auch so ein bisschen
durch die Mayo durch das ist eine
Autowaschanlage für Mayonnaise und dann
wenn gleichmäßig Mario dran ist packen
wir das Ganze und Rollen es einmal durch
den Väter ihr seht schon der bleibt
jetzt haften und jetzt eine Sache darf
nicht fehlen da hinziehen Koriander
Limette
das sieht wirklich so krank aus wieder
und wie schnell ging das jetzt und wie
einfach ist
so cremig ich weiß noch als ich das in
Miami gegessen habe habe ich gesagt
verstehe es nicht dass du was nicht in
Deutschland gibt und es gibt in
Deutschland mit 10 Minuten eurer Zeit
und es lohnt sich so sehr das ist so ein
krank geiles ausgewogenes kleines
Gericht und das perfekte Ende für
Sonntag wirklich war alles lecker es war
alles gut ich kann kein Favoriten
benennen das war so gut gegrilltes Essen
schmeckt irgendwie noch mal krasser als
normales Essen wenn ihr wollt dass wir
mehr Grillen dann zeigt das mit einem
Kommentar ich hätte auf jeden Fall
unnormal Bock hätte auch sehr groß Lust
darauf wenn wir mehr Grillen sollen dann
werden sie auch guten Appetit